the world of streaming can be unusual
show microwave show microwave show
microwave show microwave you go
microwave you're happy
it can be strange
and sometimes even downright bizarre
they're not my beans
they're not my beans so becoming known
as the weird one in this sea of oddities
is no easy feat some might even regard
it as foolish hopeless impossible but a
47 year old scottish comedian by the
name of brian lemmy lemon might just be
twitch's king of the unconventional come
here
i am your god
what though what are you doing
[Music]
sex
[Music]
so how did a mainstream funny man who
once had his own tv show end up on a
zoomer laden streaming platform how did
choosing twitch over tv change his life
for the better and how is limy bringing
awareness to what's truly important
assessment extreme threat avoiding all
circumstances i am the avoid
[Music]
hey guys before we get into lemmy's
story i just want to warn you that we
will be touching on the topics of
suicide and suicide ideation in the
video and if you or anyone you care
about has been dealing with thoughts of
self-harm we've provided some links in
the description which we hope can be
helpful all right so throughout history
scotland has graced the world with many
incredible things bagpipes kilts scotch
robbie burns the loch ness monster and
in 1974 it gave us lemmy
yes what's your shot 16 meals nice
a man whose comedy is by his own
admission and acquired taste lots of
people don't like my stuff but i like it
so that's if other people like it that's
a bonus i know it's cliche
and a self-proclaimed troll who now puts
his talents to use on twitch full time
but beneath his surface level hijinks
he's a loving father you know why spend
time with me you're saying you i spend
time with me you're the one i spent same
with me
and for those who don't know lemmy is
also a former alcoholic who openly
speaks about the dangers of addiction
the specter
of drink
is always there the other do you ever
truly beat it but long before lemmy was
any of those things he was a young lad
growing up in kamwadrik a southwestern
area of glasgow is that's a scotland
everybody
this is all we've got we've got
the nairo
who sees that's where we all live that's
where i'm right now
i'm up there that's where we all have
he graduated from glasgow caledonian
university with a degree in multimedia
technology but after 10 years of website
and flash design let me realize that his
true passion lay elsewhere see lemmy
wanted to pursue a career in comedy so
in late 2006 he started lemmy's world of
glasgow a comedic podcast where he
invented and developed unique characters
who he'd later incorporate into his
performances by 2010 limy had become
known as one of scotland's fastest
rising comedic stars and it was around
that time that he got his first big
break lemmy was approached by bbc
scotland with the offer to bring his
offbeat sense of humour to the masses in
his own tv series lemmy's show the humor
was unconventional the jokes were absurd
and the man himself deeply memeable
[Laughter]
[Music]
you prick you're the dick i said prick
that dick but i'm calling you a dick you
wink oh thank you you dick [ __ ]
i've got a question for you what's
heavier a kilogram of steel
or a kilogram of feathers that's raised
a kilogram of steel because steel is
heavier than feathers
it steals heaven feathers
i know
but they're both a kilogram
but
but despite being a certified cult
classic after three seasons the bbc
decided not to renew limy's show in the
wake of his series running its course
lemmy made youtube skits and cameos in
popular tv series wrote a few books and
continued to do stand up try and wrap
your heater in something so small
hey there
well
see that size
actual dies [ __ ]
but there was something else lemmy had
begun to dabble in alongside his
professional endeavors slowly but surely
he was getting sucked deeper into the
void that is social media
lemmy's online ventures were chugging
along well enough but he was still
trying to go the traditional route even
though his style of comedy remained
anything but that unfortunately for
lemmy he wasn't able to find the kind of
success he wanted a few more attempts at
mainstream tv later lemmy finally
announced he was quitting for good and
the reason was deeply rooted in his
longtime mental health struggles for
many people in the entertainment
industry landing a show bearing your
name on a national tv network has been
the pinnacle of success but as much as
lemmy has enjoyed the fruits of his
labor over the years the truth is it
hasn't been all peaks obviously lemie
made it through his teen years but he
had struggled with anxiety and suicidal
thoughts which would periodically
resurface throughout his adulthood and
become even more intense as he descended
into full-blown alcohol addiction i
thought to myself see that hangover and
honestly see that hang over that it felt
like it lasted for about a [ __ ] month
mentally i was mentally sort of weak and
frail for like a [ __ ] month
[Music]
and i remember thinking to
write a second i'm not myself
again the only thing that's going to get
me out of this
the only thing that's going to make me
see the light of the [ __ ] under the
tunnel here is promising myself i'm not
drinking in 2004 limmy vowed to never
drink again but in some ways his mental
health struggles were still getting
worse just something hit me same sort of
feeling that had me when i stopped
drinking i just thought you're
converging dying
you're on the verge of [ __ ] dying
this is it
you need to [ __ ] do something
he reflected on his mental state and
reached out for help after receiving the
appropriate clinical aid lemmy was
finally able to control his dark
thoughts a bit better finding a means to
financially support his family became
yet another challenge for limmy to
overcome and tv just wasn't the answer
anymore you see lemmy's whole comedic
persona was built around being deeply
unapologetically himself the good the
bad and especially the ugly and as a
result conforming to any sort of
socially acceptable standard and the
pressures of network television only
aggravated his inner demons luckily for
lemmy by 2018 there was a place that
allowed him to take full control over
the content he wanted to create without
the pressures of network ratings hanging
over his head a place where unusual
isn't just the standard but a celebrated
art that's right everyone's favorite
crass scottish joker launched his own
channel on twitch initially limi's
streams were mostly just chatting
focused but he eventually dabbled in
gaming playing titles like overwatch
papers please and subnautica
i'm so scottish look at me i'm amazing
yeah
shut it hag his head
at this point twitch was still just a
part-time experiment for lemmy but by
the time 2020 rolled around that started
to change faced with the possibility of
having to churn out more mainstream
friendly content which he absolutely
hated the thought of let me decide to go
all in on amazon's purple platform
there's some scottish people that kind
of say purple vodka
purple bugler
podpool bulgarian
what's this
pepe what the f also known as lemmy pepe
what
i will tongue your hole
okay then
somebody got caught in the rain
everybody
okay
for the first time in years libby was
free to conduct himself exactly as he
pleased and if his numbers are anything
to go by his fans were getting exactly
what they wanted as well
just all lemmy all the time this car is
full of four bushels of raisins that i'm
driving to my brother's place in
intercourse
[Music]
[Music]
now if you think limi just took whatever
audience he already had and brought them
over to twitch you're probably partially
right but there was a whole swath of his
fans who couldn't even point scotland
out on a map didn't know what sort of
programs bbc scotland ran and obviously
had no idea who lemmy was either i'm
this steel is heavier than feathers guy
i have two
baftas how can he not know who i'm
what's that
what's that
of course when you're going live for
hours at a time and you're building a
loyal audience your community is bound
to develop some inside jokes as a result
of your behavior
and we obviously couldn't make a video
about lemmy without touching on his now
iconic blams a phenomena that can't
really be explained it just has to be
experienced i think you're gonna want to
see better
but i think it first became
almost like a character there's no point
making anything look at that jawline
that's right look i was thinner and
younger looking hit subscribe
but as much as lemmy has enjoyed blaming
with his viewers over the years he's not
really the sort of guy who can keep a
low profile scone
scan
and at some point some of the bigger
names in streaming began to take notice
of lemmy's antics which only bolstered
his popularity further
quartz in my country
this is exactly like
trainspotting ha son yeah hassan abby
i can't remember your full name
all right that's free i've got a funny
accent
get over it
if this has been a worse year in your
life that means next year will be even
it will be better
if it gets worse
then congratulations this hasn't been
the worst year of your life
in the span of a few years playing over
300 different games lemmy has been able
to amass an audience of over 400 000
followers he went from being a comedian
with his own show on a national network
to being arguably twitch's unofficial
king of weird doesn't me reason
for me at the end of the like the telly
stuff what about producing for new
talent off of say brev
why this
would i want to do that and sure twitch
might not have solved all of lemmy's
problems and possibly introduced him to
some new ones he might never have
encountered anywhere else but it did
give him a place to express himself on
his terms
[Music]
and what better place to do that than on
the weird communal stomping ground that
is streaming where you don't ever have
to do it alone yes sam you happy
birthday mates let me hear all the very
best i hear you're doing really really
well and what you're doing keep up
at the end of the day everyone's got a
story to tell for some it's a tragedy
for others a comedy but for limmy it's
always been a bit of both i've bottled
up my emotions and denied how i feel
and to express myself
and it could possibly
have contributed to my self-harm when i
was 15.
for that reason
this is my bastard and [ __ ] road and
i'm not gonna let any of these [ __ ]
overtake me they can all [ __ ] off
whether he's laughing swearing or
dropping some profound truth bombs lemmy
has taken control of the narrative and
proved to us all that being open to
changing course is one of the greatest
gifts you can ever give yourself thanks
for watching
by the fantastic team as usual
[Music]
oh god he's got one where he mocks like
american sports the new york jet hawks
with the fourth base in the second
quarter of the fifth inning i'm so
intrigued by these soundups it's mad
this sound up is so funny there's
nothing you've seen this one purple
parkour